I'm from New Orleans and I think it's
shaped me rather ethically especially of
late I grew up there I actually was not
born there i was born in Missouri but my
family is from there and I only lived
outside of New Orleans for three years
so it's really my hometown my
grandparents my mother's family all my
cousins my sister was born there my
daughter was born there so it's really
my home although I have not lived there
in the last 20 years or so I visit a lot
I think being from New Orleans is not
like being from any other city in the
country possibly in the world it's a
place all unto itself it's very a very
difficult frustrating wonderful place
and full of really gothic and romantic
stories about it's about its own past
and and very gothic feelings about
itself very multi-ethnic one of the most
multi-ethnic places especially in the
period when I was growing up in the
country and it has just a fabulous
history and I think as far as my writing
is concerned but before I left norms it
was a lot more gothic that it is now but
people would say that and I had no idea
what they were talking about um Flannery
O'Connor makes a remark in one of her
stories no I'm sorry to door Welty that
everybody in New Orleans believes
everything spooky and that I think
that's a pretty good summation of of the
basic ethnos of that city
well it's changed in a number of ways
and change radically recently of course
I you know I get when I grew up it was
we still had those signs you won't know
those signs but they had signs on the on
the streetcar that they were like wooden
signs and they were holes at the top of
each seat in these signs could be moved
back and forth in the streetcar or in
the bus and they sign said for our color
patrons only and people of color when
they got on the bus had to sit behind
the sign but it was a movable sign so
sometimes they move it all the way up
and you'd wind up sitting actually
across from a person of color but we
were not allowed white people were not
allowed to sit behind asylum so it was
absurd it was just bizarre but it was a
given of daily life another one was
faucets that had done I think it was the
same thing colored over one of them
nothing over the other one and obviously
no need to describe us and I remember as
a girl running over to one of the
faucets that said colored because I
thought it would be colored water and
getting my arm yanked out my socket so I
was very different world from the world
that is that city now and that all
started to change I guess as I was
growing up and even up until I was in
high school in this in the 60s that's
when those signs disappeared I had a
friend who was so aggravated by one as a
boy that he threw it out the window so
there was it was a long time coming but
it was all coming throughout my life the
sort of breakdown in in just this overt
kind of racism and then that of course
the big change has been in the last few
years that the drowning of New Orleans
the destruction of the city which is
just devastating and it's it's not
recovering very well in my view
well except you know a racism when it's
in the in saddle is a verte it's just
nobody questions it on either side it's
understood that this is the way things
are done I saw really more more
unpleasant and overt racism when I went
to visit my grandparents in Missouri
because in that city in that way was a
little town by people literally lived on
one side of a track and white people in
the other New Orleans has always had a
real mix of neighborhoods so that you
know very wealthy people with a block
away from very poor people and that's
that's made it a very different it's a
little harder to know I guess it's not
hard for some people but it's it's a
little harder to pretend that your
neighbors are now real real people and
it's always had such a large percentage
of people of color and it's had from a
very early point a good population of
free people of color people who were
never slaves who came to New Orleans
from Haiti and owned property and could
even vote and um could sue which was
something that was not available to
people of color anywhere else in the
country at that time so it was a very
it's a very peculiar city and its race
relations and you know I've described it
as being both of the most races in the
least racist place I've ever been and
and I think that is true in my
experience I've certainly found a kind
of deeper and crueler racism in other
parts of the country just because people
don't you know they never see a person
of color and when they do it's this it's
it's something special it's not it's not
another person it's an exotic in some
way which is a kind of racism in itself